>> 20 IS A BIG NUMBER.
THIS ISN'T LIKE A MARGINAL
THING.
HE'S GOT TO TURN THREE-QUARTERS
OF THESE PEOPLE AROUND, BUT LET
ME TELL YOU SOMETHING, JAKE SAID
THAT HE'S MADE A CORNUCOPIA OF
CONCESSIONS.
HE SURRENDERED.
THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS
WHETHER THE 20 ACCEPT IT OR NOT,
THEY WON.
EITHER McCARTHY BECOMES A
NEUTERED POWERLESS SPEAKER WHO
HAS A SORT OF DAMOCLES OVER HIS
HEAD THAT COULD FALL AT ANY TIME
BECAUSE ANYBODY IN THAT BODY
COULD CALL TO VACATE THE CHAIR
OR SOMEONE ELSE BECOMES SPEAKER,
BUT THEY HAVE WON THIS.
I MEAN THE ONLY THING THAT'S
LEFT IS ONE TO DRIVE OUT WITH
McCARTHY'S CAR AND ANOTHER ONE
TO WEAR HIS COAT AND I MEAN HE'S
GIVEN EVERYTHING AWAY.
>> BUT, DO YOU THINK IF YOU GIVE
IN -- IF McCARTHY GIVES IN HERE
TO THESE FOLKS, WHOEVER IS NEXT
IS GOING TO --
>> MY CONCERN IS NOT FOR THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
MY CONCERN IS FOR THE COUNTRY.
THIS IS A PRECURSOR OF AN AWFUL
COUPLE OF YEARS.
>> THAT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT
POINT BECAUSE, AGAIN, GIVING ALL
THE THINGS HE'S GIVING AWAY NOT
AT WHAT COST BUT WHAT WILL THAT
LOOK LIKE OVER THE NEXT COUPLE
OF YEARS IF EVERY DAY, EVERY
WEEK WE ARE BACK HERE HAVING TO
VOTE AGAIN?
NOTHING IS GOING TO MOVE.
YOU KNOW, THE OTHER THING I DO
WANT TO SAY, THIS IS EXACTLY
WHAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE VOTED
AGAINST, YOU HAVE A HANDFUL OF
MAGA EXTREMISTS, DESTRUCTIONISTS
I WOULD CALL THEM BASICALLY
HOLDING THE UNITED STATES HOUSE
HOSTAGE OVER THE THINGS THAT
THEY WANT WHICH IS NOT THE T
THINGS THAT A MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS VOTED FOR.
WE VOTED FOR, WE WANT YOU TO GET
THINGS DONE BY, BY THE WAY, YOUR
FORMER BOSS GOT.
MITCH McCONNELL SENT A STRONG
MESSAGE ATO THE HOUSE TO SAY I'M
NOT GOING TO PLAY THAT GAME WITH
Y'ALL.
>> THE HOUSE DOESN'T HAVE TO DO
A TON OF STUFF.
NEEDS TO PASS A BUDGET.
WILL HAVE TO DO THE DEBT LIMIT
AND PASS APPROPRIATIONS BILLS
BUT THOSE THREE THINGS, IF YOU
COULDN'T WRANGLE THESE FIVE TO
TEN PEOPLE THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN
THE REPUBLICANS ARE BEGGING
DEMOCRATS -- BY THE WAY, THE
HELP WON'T COME FOR FREE.
YOU'LL END UP WITH REPUBLICANS
HAVING TO GIVE AWAY GOODNESS
KNOWS WHAT TO HAKEEM JEFFRIES TO
GET THE VOTES TO DO THE BASIC
FUNCTIONING OF THE GOVERNMENT
WHICH NO REPUBLICAN VOTED FOR I
CAN ASSURE YOU.
WHOEVER BECOMES SPEAKER I STILL
THINK McCARTHY HAS A GOOD CHANCE
BUT WHAT DOES THIS PORTEND FOR
THE FUTURE?
>> THOSE DISCUSSIONS HAVE
HAPPENED, BY THE WAY BETWEEN
MODERATE REPUBLICANS AND SOME ON
THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE WHO
EXPRESSED A WILLINGNESS TO
CONSIDER IT BUT WHAT THEY'VE
BEEN TOLD IS McCARTHY DOESN'T
WANT TO DO THAT BECAUSE HE
FEELS -- THIS IS THE BOX HE'S
IN, TO COOPERATE WITH DEMOCRATS
IS A DEATH SENTENCE FOR HIM AS
WELL.
SO HE'S REALLY IN A TERRIBLE
POSITION.
>> LISTEN, I DON'T THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE AS BAD AS YOU'D LIKE
TO SEE AND PREDICT.
ONCE YOU GET THE SPEAKER YOU'LL
HAVE ROBUST OVERSIGHT FROM JIM
JORDAN OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AND ROBUST OVERSIGHT
OF THE BORDER BY WHOEVER THE
CHAIRMAN OF HOMELAND SECURITY
IS.
THERE'S GOING TO BE AGGRESSIVE
OVERSIGHT.
AS I SAID BEFORE OVERSIGHT BY A
MAJORITY OF ONE FEELS --
>> I'M NOT LOOKING FOR CHAOS.
WHAT I'M WORRIED ABOUT IS, FOR
EXAMPLE, WHEN THE DEBT CEILING
HAS TO BE --
>> THAT'S IN AUGUST?
AND THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
DOES THE RESPONSIBLE THICK AND
DOESN'T LET THE COUNTRY DEFAULT
ON ITS CREDIT, THAT WILL ALMOST
CERTAINLY TRIGGER FUNCTIONS AND
YOU'LL HAVE ANOTHER ONE OF THESE
WILL BE ALL SITTING AROUND HERE
WATCHING THE ROLL BEING CALLED.
>> THAT'S BEEN A REPUBLICAN
PROBLEM EVERY TIME WE APPROACH
THE DEBT CEILING.
THEY STRUGGLE WITH THAT.
IT'S NOT A McCARTHY PROBLEM.
>> BUT NOT AT THE RISK OF
BEING --
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> NOT AT THE RISK OF BEING
PROPOSED.
>> SO AS WE'RE HEARING THESE IN
THE BACK OF OUR EARS, MATT GAETZ
WHO OBVIOUSLY HAS -- IS ONE OF
THE NEVER, NEVER, NEVER JUST
VOTED FOR TRUMP.
SO --
>> TRYING TO GET BACK IN GOOD
GRACES.
MAYBE LAUREN BOEBERT WILL VOTE
FOR TRUMP TOO SINCE SHE TOLD HIM
TO SHUT UP AND GO AWAY.
>> THAT IS A BIG ISSUE.
HE HAD NO IMPACT ON THESE -- THE
PURIST MAGA CONGRESSMEN.
>> HE'S COME OUT AND SAID -- HE
DID.
>> HE HAS NO IMPACT.
NOT ONLY DID HE HAVE NO IMPACT
AND BOEBERT GOES DOWN TO THE
FLOOR ORDERING HIM AROUND IN
PUBLIC.
IT WAS KIND OF HUMILIATING
TRUTHFULLY.
>> I COULD PREDICT WITH 100%
CERTAINTY THAT DONALD TRUMP WILL
NOT BE SENDING LAUREN BOEBERT A
CHRISTMAS CARD NEXT YEAR.
>> YOU KNOW, I WAS LOOKING AT A
POLL THAT CAME OUT THIS WEEK AND
THERE WERE RATINGS OF VARIOUS
LEGISLATIVE LEADERS AND NANCY
PELOSI AMONG DEMOCRATS WAS
73-19, KEVIN McCARTHY AMONG
REPUBLICANS, 42-33.
IT'S NOT LIKE HE'S A BELOVED
FIGURE AMONG REPUBLICANS, SO
THEY'RE FIGHTING OVER A GUY, YOU
KNOW, NO ONE WANTS TO STORM THE
RAMPARTS FOR --
>> WHAT REPUBLICAN LEADER IS?
OUR SPORT IS KICKING THE CRAP
OUT OF OUR OWN LEADERSHIP.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE, YOU KNOW,
THERE'S BEEN INTERNAL WRANGLINGS
HERE BUT ULTIMATELY YOU UPLIFT
YOUR LEADERS AND UPLIFTED NANCY
PELOSI BUT WE ARE LIKE CRABS IN
A BUCKET.
WE HAVE BEEN FOR 12 YEAR, ONE
CLIENTS TO THE TOP AND EVERYBODY
TRIES TO DRAG HIM DOWN.
BY THE WAY, THERE ARE
CONSEQUENCES TO THAT ATTITUDE
AND WE'RE SEEING IT TODAY.
>> BUT ALSO CONSIDER THAT NANCY
PELOSI, I MEAN, THERE'S ALSO A
GENERATIONAL ISSUE GOING ON HERE
WITH THESE -- THE FIVE OF THE
20.
I HAVE TO REMEMBER MY NUMBERS,
RIGHT, IN TERMS OF HOW THEY VIEW
WHAT THEIR JOB REALLY IS.
THEY VIEW THEIR JOB AS GETTING
CLICKS, RAISING MONEY, CREATING
CHAOS.
NOT ACTUALLY LEGISLATING.
>> MISSION ACCOMPLISHED.
>> BUT THEY'RE NOT INTERESTED IN
LEGISLATING.
PELOSI UNDERSTOOD WHERE HER
CAUCUS WAS, HOW TO GET PEOPLE
WHAT THEY WANTED, WHAT THEY
NEEDED.
THE FACT THAT, FOR EXAMPLE, YOU
HAVE KEVIN McCARTHY JUST MET
WITH SOME OF THE FRESHMEN WAS IT
LAST NIGHT?
HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN DOING THAT
OVER THE HOLIDAY TO TRY TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE THE CAUCUS WAS
WHEN HE CAME IN.
>> I DON'T THINK ANYBODY HERE,
THESE GUY, ANYBODY, WOULD
DISAGREE.
PELOSI WAS A LEGISLATIVE GENIUS.
GREAT AT WHAT SHE DID.
BUT THERE'S A BIG GAP BETWEEN
BEING A LEGISLATIVE GENIUS AND
WHAT WE'VE SEEN THESE LAST FEW
DAYS WHICH HAVE BEEN A PARADE OF
ERRORS.
YOU KNOW, JOHN F. KENNEDY SAID
IN HIS INAUGURAL ADDRESS IN A
DIFFERENT CONTEXT, THOSE WHO
FOOLISHLY SOUGHT POWER BY RIDING
THE BACK OF THE TIGER ENDED UP
INSIDE.
THAT'S A LITTLE OF WHAT'S GOING
ON RIGHT NOW.
KEVIN McCARTHY HAS BEEN
PLACATING THESE PEOPLE FOR YEARS
AND NOW HE MAY END UP INSIDE.
RIGHT NOW YOU ARE WATCHING KEVIN
McCARTHY HEADED TO HIS SEVENTH
DEFEAT IN HIS EFFORTS TO BE
NAMED TO BE ELECTED SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE.
HE NEEDS TO WIN 218 VOTES.
HE CAN ONLY AFFORD TO LOSE FOUR
HOUSE REPUBLICANS.
HE HAS ALREADY LOST TEN HOUSE
REPUBLICANS.
WE KNEW THAT WAS THE LIKELY
OUTCOME TODAY, AUDI ORNISH.
WE WERE LOOKING TO SEE IF THERE
WAS ANY MOVEMENT WITH ALL THE
CONCESSIONS HE MADE WITH RULES
AND PROCEDURES AND MANY CHIP ROY
AND THE OTHERS HAVE BEEN ASKING
FOR BUT AS OF NOW I HAVE NOT
SEEN ANY OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
WHO CLAIM TO CARE ABOUT RULES
CHANGES, CHANGE THEIR VOTES AT
ALL.
>> RIGHT, I THINK IF YOU'RE
WATCHING AT HOME UNDERSTAND EACH
ONE OF THESE VOTES SENDS A
SIGNAL OR A MESSAGE, YOU DON'T
ACTUALLY HAVE TO KNOW EVERY
SINGLE NUMBER WHICH WAY, YOU
JUST IS HAVE TO SEE, IS IT
CHANGING DIRECTIONALLY?
AND KEVIN McCARTHY LAST NIGHT
DIDN'T WANT TO HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL VOTE AT 8:00 BECAUSE
HE SAID WE NEED PORE TIME.
IT'S BEEN A WHOLE NIGHT.
WE'RE INTO THE NEXT DAY AND THE
NUMBERS AREN'T MOVING IN THE
DIRECTION HE WOULD LIKE SO WHAT
IS THE SIGNAL EVERYONE ELSE IS
TRYING TO SEND IS THE QUESTION
WE SHOULD ASK OURSELVES AND IS
THERE ANOTHER DEMAND OR ANOTHER
NAME?
AND I DON'T KNOW, EVERYONE ELSE
HERE HAS CELL PHONES WITH MORE
PEOPLE IN IT THAN ME BUT I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THOSE SORT OF WANTS
ARE AT THIS POINT.
>> LET'S BRING IN AN ALLY OF
KEVIN McCARTHY, FORMER
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN RODNEY
DAVIS.
FIRST OF ALL, HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
I CAN'T IMAGINE YOU WOULD RATHER
SPEND YOUR BIRTHDAY DOING
ANYTHING OTHER THAN SITTING IN A
ROOM BY YOURSELF ANSWERING OUR
QUESTIONS WHEN WE CHOOSE TO COME
TO YOU SO HAPPY BIRTHDAY BUT I
HAVE TO SAY, I WAS TOLD
YESTERDAY BY HOUSE REPUBLICAN,
SUPPORTER OF KEVIN McCARTHY,
THAT THE SUDDEN MOVE TO ADJOURN
AT 8:00 P.M. AFTER SAYING THEY
WERE GOING TO RECONVENE WAS
BECAUSE OF FEARS THAT SOMEONE
WAS GOING TO BRING UP STEVE
SCALISE AND NOMINATE STEVE
SCALISE AND YOU JUST HEARD KEN
BUCK A FEW MINUTES AGO TELLING
ME THAT IF McCARTHY DOES NOT WIN
THIS TODAY, HE WILL LIKELY OR HE
WILL POSSIBLY PUT STEVE
SCALISE'S NAME AS A NOMINATION
FOR THE SPEAKERSHIP.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS GOING ON
RIGHT NOW.
>> FIRST OF ALL, THANKS FOR THE
BIRTHDAY WISHES.
IT'S A JOY TO BE ALONE IN HERE
BUT ON THE FLOOR WATCHING THAT
CIRCUS IN I WAS IN CONGRESS
AGAIN.
BUT IN THE END I HAVE NOT HEARD
THAT WAS THE REASON WHY THEY
WANTED TO GO TO CONFERENCE AND
ADJOURN LAST NIGHT.
I HEARD THE REASON THAT THEY
WANTED TO ADJOURN LAST NIGHT,
JAKE, WAS TO ACTUALLY GO
NEGOTIATE.
>> SURE.
>> I'VE HEARD THEY HAD FRUITFUL
NEGOTIATIONS BUT IN THE END, IN
THE END, THIS VOTE IS GOING TO
BE A TELLTALE SIGN AS MANY OF
YOU HAVE MENTIONED ALL DAY.
WHETHER OR NOT THERE WILL BE
CHANGES LOOK SPECIFICALLY AT
CHIP ROY.
IF CHIP DECIDES TO CHANGE HIS
VOTE TO McCARTHY OR PRESENT,
THAT'S PROGRESS.
AND IF CHIP CAN LIVE UP TO THE
COMMITMENT TO GET TEN PEOPLE TO
COME WITH HIM, I THINK YOU'LL
START TO SEE SOME PRESSURE GOING
TOWARD McCARTHY AND PROGRESS
GOING TOWARD McCARTHY TOO.